joining me here on the Rich Eisen show
is my compadre from the NFL Network
Sunday gameday morning Michael Irvin
Canton class of 2007 ten years Irv
already ten years late and to your right
across from me is a man who is abducted
the Pro Football Hall of Fame two years
ago also the Dallas Cowboys together
Michael Irvin with Charles Haley good to
see you Charles how are you I'm ready
right that I'm scared as well which I'll
tell you as well today David you didn't
give me my props oh I'm a Hall of Fame
but my five-time Super Bowl champion -
you know a lot of times - yeah I'm a
badass I saw at my camp a couple weeks
ago and I teach them as that rested you
know everybody's talking about Tom Brady
and five six five rings Charles had five
rings before all of that and not often I
get introduced someone that has more
rings than I do so it was cool to
introduce Charles even though I was
worried by what he's going to tell my
kids now Michael you you've known me for
a very very long time
okay you've known my career that you
were at my wedding at my wedding day me
and my beautiful wife Suzy who had a
birthday yesterday of all happy birthday
San Diego of all the decisions that I
have made you've seen me make where does
putting Charles Haley on a live radio
show at no delay put where to next and
right Ellie your buddy you home okay
well if you did did you take your
medicine today no okay good okay it is
gonna hey what you what you and Michael
having this come see I thought no no no
I brought you in well the time I know I
do
okay what kind of questions on your
right I am scared yeah I hear you how
does it feel to be a returning Hall of
Famer Charles Haley um it feels great
the best part of it is is you know my
two owners buy here each year and I just
it's amazing what what they brought to
the table 80 into 80s and early 90s and
I'm one of with the 49ers arms I didn't
trust Pete
so our verse stand on [ __ ] so I didn't
really get to know mr. day but but I
knew what he did for us I knew what he
did for people and he was the most
caring man I ever met in my life and
he's still that same way
ain't no when I when I came to Dallas
you know after this and I had all that
smoke at $49 and then they put me on
that play dog I hey so I'm and they told
me don't come back okay and I so I came
to Dallas and Jerry met me at the
airport sherry went down they got my
with me carry my luggage out I'm going
like this is not the damn owner the
Dallas Cowboys and I so we got in the
car we wouldn't be encountered y'all he
carried your luggage free we pulled you
know I hit on rollers but he ain't hey
bruh that's why I said he was known I
thought they were lied to be honest I
thought I thought they were doing what a
brother does I'm gonna like them I just
got to doubt that they play a tricks of
it you know and so we got in the car and
the hotel is probably five minutes where
it took out he told me every mistake he
made he told me how much money he was
hemorrhaging from the Cowboys and he
told me what his vision was and then
just [ __ ] out the car seat I got your
back man I mean I was dejected but when
he said that man I'm like okay I'll
fight for you son I'll fight for you you
know and then I got the opportunity to
step out on the field with those guys
out there like Michael it was a bunch of
thoroughbreds running up there oh Lord
so we will have some fun now what would
you like my god he was in yeah but what
Charles talking about is it was him
cause were only two owners in that inner
in our luncheon today they shot a lot
and that's alive right now but but I
talked about it's like you guys go tell
the rest of these owners that they did
that that that it's a difference we guys
like this because these guys here they
went beyond just to football with each
player they had it would beyond the
football they worked on the man and you
know we always talked about
it's owner football guys it's on a
football everybody no X's and O's but
not everybody no people and that makes
the difference man it was that was a
great luncheon having Geryon and the new
class is coming in our three guys from
the network you know and King he's lead
more than Anderson man it was just a
great luncheon in a great time
Charles Haley and Michael Irvin together
here on the Rich Eisen show but so what
was it like when Charles walked through
that door after all the battles that you
had with the 49ers and now man I could
star on the slaughter helmet I remember
when we first started playing we were
not that good and Charles was playing
and behind him was Danny Stubblefield
who played with me at Miami and still
used to call me when we got ready to
femto and this is Michael Winkle Michael
McGlinn swim if you just come down and
he legally crack back on Charles vane
I'll pay you my game check let's just
get him not out of the game I behaved
Shaw so much before I met her
I never know Chucky and I could imagine
what you must have done to study because
Danny Summerfield was crazy to himself
what did you get ring what did you do
then I didn't give my damn job you know
what I told you hey you want to take
this and every day you know what you
have to smash people you there's only
one dog one alpha dog and you know it
can't be too so um so you know they
learned that very quickly and you know
the things of my life was is consistency
and hard work you know there's no
different easy way to be great and guys
want to skip all the way to being great
and don't put the work and I don't stand
for that and um you know there's there's
repercussion to people's action
repercussions and even if you are
willing to put the work here you still
got to do what reconcussions charles is
just going to be on you milk truly all
the time and I'm serious and we needed
we had a young group of guys young
defensive line and everything with
Charles came in I mean he just took it
to another level they came in everybody
was like oh my god you know we heard all
the stories coming over from San
Francisco were they true yeah something
I wanted to ask
about how did you really you know pee
all in the car man's car like that right
and about here is our forget it you have
to convert they say I got you another
second to comb her hair convertible now
I got man
you gonna for the call so that's what
stores we ran down a lot of the night to
come home heroes like hold on mistakes
okay so the story was that that dem
Harris they say that IP told Tim Harris
in Tim Harris car and now what happened
was we were at Benihana [ __ ] his knee at
me and Tim okay now they broke two men
to take my job and I'm so he was another
guy they had to learn to hearing or do
that and so we would go there because
traffic is real bad so we went down we
were drunk to go back to the facility
and the doors locked and oh brother had
the piece I peed in between the car and
then how did it become a story Charles
Charles Haleakala how do I become a
story that you peed again a scar they
wanted a security guys was looking at
the camera and put the story out now
me and Tim up we're the great friends
you know you paying somebody car dang on
be your friend you know yeah that that
would be called a friendship break right
right yeah yeah you know but let me tell
you something man the 49ers stood for
something you know I was looking up to
walk into a locker room with leaders you
know these young guys don't even
understand cuz they don't get to walk in
with God's are gonna be in the Hall of
Fame and you know what I I didn't I'm
bipolar I did not understand me all our
understood was is that you ain't go
called me out you know Ronnie we was in
a meeting and I'm running to got up a
lot running a lot yeah he got up and now
you know he was on criticizing and you
know I'm that look you know Chuck came
out see Charles of being
and then Rana did that damn truck came
out so I I walked outside the door you
know no because you know I'm I'm trying
to give him the benefit of dummy I
walked out then and Chuck came on Chuck
told Ronnie hey next time you do it I'm
gonna kill your ass you know I'm saying
and I'm and and you know I truly believe
that I would because I don't I don't I
don't take criticism well I'll go be a
watch when he was he was a coach he told
me criticism is just like beef jerky
it's hard to chew but it has everything
you would need in it and you need some
damn criticize all aw come on I want to
take a 60-second break
why yes can you go out because I have to
I have to it I don't know where you make
your money well that's my break my power
up your are you know you got to be
scared that's not just you you'll know
which other gets it back I just H all
right now there will be here 60 seconds
later hopefully Chucky won't be he'll
come back thank you okay hopefully
Michael Irvin Charles not Chucky Haley
back here in 60 seconds here on the Reg
- ship cessation with Michael Irvin pro
football of Famer Canton class of 2007
in Charles Haley from a couple of years
ago you broke the dam you got in and
then Eddie D got in and now Jerry Jones
has got hey I didn't break the dam those
gusts I deserve it
their body of work speaks for themselves
so now do you think Jerry Jones is going
to because that's that's a conversation
that's always had amongst Pro Football
Hall of Famers it's who and the incoming
class is going to cry during their
speeches do you think Jerry Jones will
break down I surely do cuz you know what
um you ever talk to Jerry about a dad oh
my god his dad you know when your dad
passed he took us down he threw all of
us down to the funeral the team I don't
know just a group of guy look at he
respect and we went down man I mean a
and then he did another show and and I
mean he broke down and um you know it's
understandable you know with somebody
impact your life like that
you know it's you know something special
I tell you I remember um 1807 when my
wife and I went into his office and
asked him to present us you know at the
hall and when I walked in you know of
course Jerry he always wants to get the
hard stuff out of the way he's like a
royalty and Sarah is everything okay
that's boss we're okay everything's good
there's no trouble because locater was
what's up what he guys wanted right I
think it's it well we've been thinking
about it and my wife and I and we want
we want you to present us and he started
crying then he was just so overwhelmed
and he said Michael you don't know what
this means to me call his wife because
she was he called her on the
speakerphone
she was crying my wife were crying we
were all crying in the room
I cannot imagine if that moment of you
asking him to present me at the Hall of
things made him tear up like that and
this moment is going to be that moment
times 20 for him
I cannot imagine I'm not shedding a tear
at that moment you know and you're going
through what all Charles were just
talking about remembering what I call
all the miracles on your journey all the
people that helped you get to where you
are right now in and I say this in the
person that's presenting him we could
talk about Jerry Jones accomplishments
play forever but his greatest
accomplishment was locking down Jean
Jones that's his greatest accomplishment
if she is going to be on stage she is
the ultimate class beauty style
everything I like in her wrist to
Jacqueline Kennedy Onassis everybody
always told our stop that's what she is
I'm serious you don't ever see her in
public she's always right there and
she's going and she's going to present
him kick Saturday night watch what I
tell you there's no way he doesn't cry
you're out over there just with all that
man I don't know though you know you
know Gigi there's great I like I love
what I love lies that stick with it and
stick to it no matter what and she has
done that like my wife has oh my god
your wife has
[Laughter]
you know what Michael tells it like that
it does I hope Michael wanted me to come
down talk to kids about adversity right
so as I was driving then when you get
when he called me and said that I'm
going like what the hell he won't be
there here for you you talk about a
birthday present like you know so you
know but but you know what we all been
through and and you know what
it's either make you stronger or weaker
and those are giants that's in our life
that we conquered it didn't conquer us
we conquered it and you know it made us
a better man I can't ignore what I stand
here broken you know and you know like I
said I'm bipolar
you know I've hurt my family I've done
it all and and I still stand tall and
like I tell people it doesn't matter
that's not not blessing my blessing is
not the things I did in my past my
blessing is what I'm doing now and
that's Matt Michaels blessing you know
what we stumble but you know what we get
back up and we get back up because you
know what what we always done Charles
Haley Michael Irvin here on the Rich
Eisen show um how lips is the Jones
party going to be tonight really because
I've heard I've heard some thoughts on
what what's planned entertainment was
what do you think oh yeah it's going to
be like you guys hear the invitation
only
okay he's my plus Walker okay why you go
totally date okay she's my wife I hope
we put a wig on doing I'm not gonna
argue with you you know that hey they
got a magic shop maybe they can help you
be shorter now he's allergic to you like
just what is that
we other singles you know everybody in
the room know you talk he's just trying
to stay out of your hair but you won't
talk now I'm just trying to stay out
you're not even looking at you know you
won't even make eye contact with Charles
Hill I'm frightened why he's a
sweetheart look at it look at my teeth
he's smiling yeah oh it's a it's a
question me at all
do I need to wear a tie tonight what
would you want
thank you but if you were a time you are
tired you make me mayor guess what it's
going to be a loose a read why I should
not wear a tie for talk but here we go
I'll talk or talk at all yeah yeah yeah
everybody came everybody come in man we
we would draft first rounders like
shuntay Carver these guys befriended
through banners dude man do the first
round drastic difference again and Chuck
it Jim beat his brain down hit by the
tight it was really no good after about
a year or so you know chunky Haley oh my
god he just beat him down man he would
say I'm trying to find out if he's at
all I'm trying to know you break it this
man it would break people if you're not
a strong is that whose carnitine oh did
you pee in this town no no to see that
day you go with rumors how will this get
started hey but you know why what guys
don't understand is you know I talked to
him a couple weeks ago at the star and
you know he was telling me I looked at
you the father figure blah blah blah
I said Brooke they drafted you to take
my job ain't go give it to you and so
you know what you can one all day but
you know some I didn't give it to you I
say and I gave you all the opportunities
I didn't go out to practice much but
when I did I brought it you know saying
hey hey you know what Chuck said Chuck
is say you know hey he put the book he
put the paint on Charles and Chuckie
brought the hel-hello
your badge event the greatest thing in
the world being locker room without
everyday Wow every day I one thing I
would say I didn't have to worry about
the defense I knew it was going to
collect so he you either play against to
do a deal with each other and you rather
than going on be that duel across from
and then the deal with sure but you know
you know my first year with them we went
to Mexico so Michael had to get his
passport and he checked other cuz he
sold all key blue so you had to put blue
there I began to people blue line around
odd I was really caught on Charles alien
Michael Irvin this has been a blast
thank the jury appreciate it
I'll see you tonight at the at the Jonas
novel it's a jacket in rare exactly
gender gonna get you guys out on time I
primary weekend alright but Michael
Irvin thank you okay thank you everybody
last your closure convertible close the
top they better like to do it Michael
Irvin's in town and close the top
Charles Haley Ted to the park in the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on radio stations across the country and
audience if you like that del Mona rap
please just give it's a memory thing
just delete other apps you don't need
those apps this app the Rich Eisen show
app you need that